when did you realize the you made the
first transformers it made like a
billion dollars
huge hit when did you realize when you
were before you were making it during
during making it or was it after that
you realized oh this is going to be a
huge movie okay okay i'll i'll explain
so spielberg calls me i'll keep this
short for the people over universal here
okay
um spielberg called me up uh i was
sitting in my head a room in santa
monica he goes michael i'd like you to
do transformers it's about a boy
who's getting his car
first car and it turns into a nail it
turns in it's it's an it's an alien
transformers and i'm like i literally
swear to god i i did not grow up with
transformers i i hung up the phone and i
literally said
this is a bad idea
so every studio in town turned the movie
down
and i said to deference stephen i went
to uh hasbro met with the ceo and i went
to transformer school
and i remember when brian goldner ceo of
hasbro and you it's
very cool you walked hasbro you see
literally the very first monopoly board
created on a on a on a
tablecloth okay the checkered
red and white tablecloth and you see mr
potato head and all these toys that i
played with when i was a kid
and i'm like i sit in this big boardroom
they show you how they're unfolding this
stuff they start giving you the lore
um which i really liked but i remember
zoning in on an anime and an anime
japanese anime picture behind the ceo
and
and movies sometimes it's one image that
can spark a movie and i uh the script
was not good at first and i'm like you
probably
whatever okay let's just move on
i thought to myself wow if i make these
robots really real
if they were if you could believe that
because effects were not that advanced
at that time and i'll explain that
um and this image came to my my head
where
what if a kid is trying to hide these
robots that are that are 20 30 feet
behind his house and his parents are
inside i said to me that was the movie
and that's which wish fulfillment
fulfillment and it was about can we make
this lifelike and can we make because
these things will reflect 10 000 pieces
of light it's never been done in visual
effects and it kind of changed the game
we lost the oscar and that was [ __ ]
but whatever okay all right
i agree
um
but uh
uh
where am i in the story you're talking
about the the you're in the you've got
it was wish fulfillment okay okay so all
right so so now we're transformers and
friday night the guys would come to my
my i have a bar we have drinks and beers
[ __ ] whatever and i've got this i
like surrounding myself with normal
people and i'm not into the hollywood
scene and
um they keep you grounded and i'd make
movies for audiences and i'm not into
all this like you know whatever um
and this guy mike fisher who's was a
former
uh pro quarterback from texas he's like
hey bae i mean i mean i really like
really scott movies i'm like i do too
mike and he goes
he goes you know i i don't know bae i
mean this transformer thing you're doing
i don't know i'm like yeah and then you
just start feeling terrible about
yourself i'm like yeah i know oh god
yeah and then i i remember the first day
of the shoot
we shot
tyreese running
and scorpinox diving out of the sand and
diving right behind him and that was the
first effect they did and ilm did it
and then i remember showing it to mike
fisher
uh my screening room he goes oh man i
okay i get it now i get it now so that
that's how that happened
uh my only other question about
transformers you obviously made a bunch
of transformers movies and would do you
think because you
i don't obviously you made the first one
and you were never sure how many you
were going to make you weren't sure if
you were going to do a sequel would you
have done actually anything differently
with the storylines had you known you
were going to make more of them do you
know what i mean yeah because it was
always a one-off and you never knew
you're going to do a whole thing so
literally we did one
and it was weird when we were doing the
first one and then peter jackson had
seen the the trailer he called spielberg
he goes that movie's going to be huge
and i didn't know um but but when you
saw with the audience it's like
like the test screening here's a test
screening okay
let me just give you experience as a
director at a test screening where you
we fill up an audience way bigger than
this 400 people
and we have two houses we have
families in one house 400 people and
then the next house starts 15 minutes
later that's uh more adults
and you sit there i sit on the side and
i've got the sound
knob and people in the front hate
because i turn it louder as it goes and
um
and i'm watching this and i'm like and
this movie's not complete and i'm like
oh my god oh this is just a dumb kid
movie this is terrible
and i think this is awful then i go to
the next theater
watch that and now we're in the adult
thing and there's empty seat and then
there's this dude sitting next to me
and halfway through and i'm like i want
to throw up oh my god oh my god oh my
god all directors do by the way that's
just the way it goes and i go to the guy
and said do you like this movie and he
he doesn't know who i am he goes
and i'm like oh my god i'm so depressed
so it was a crazy night so the studio's
all there studios all nervous and the
the score and the the the family uh
theater was a 94 which is a massive
score for an unfinished movie and then
same one for the adult was 94. so i'm
like okay maybe there's something here
and there you go it was a billion
dollars
whatever um
anyway
jumping into why i actually i'm talking
to you tonight ambulance right ambulance
hang on wait let me ask you a question
did you guys like it
yeah oh really okay
what
you love it
come on let's hear that what you say
what you say
you didn't like it i love it
uh
so uh i'm
with casting this how was it in terms of
did you know what is it like for you to
cast a movie nowadays is it literally
you texting people and saying no i was
lucky i mean the these the the asa was
my sixth choice jake was my seventh and
yaya was my first no i'm kidding that's
a total joke total joke and you better
erase any of that if you shot it okay
that's a total sarcastic joke um i've
always wanted to work with
jake and um
i i told my agent was i was right i'm
writing a big movie with a a
big writer and i i just wanted to get
back i love shooting i'm very passionate
i don't even have a director chair on my
set i don't have video village i don't
have a trailer i'm the type of director
that splatters the blood holds a camera
i'm right there uh with actors and you
heard that word that bayhem thing right
it's not my word i'd not create that by
cruz created that because
uh i like to keep it fast and this was a
very fast movie i called my agent i know
i'm rambling right now but
um i i said i just want to do something
fast and intense and
uh he says well there's a script that's
spinning sitting around on the uh
bradley how long has it been sitting
there this is one of the producers
bradley
fisher about how many how many
six or seven years sitting so um uh and
i read it and i was developing a crime
story because i i was developing another
crime story that was sort of i wanted to
have an aw
the audience feel like they're on a
crime that goes south really fast just
keep it intense and this had a lot of
those markings and reworked the script a
bit
um
and
okay where are we i was asking about how
did you get the three of them so so okay
the business was getting very very busy
which means people were getting booked
everywhere it was cobin was still going
on and people are figuring out a way to
do it safe
and um
uh and it's hard to get availabilities
of actors and jake
jake uh
i got the word that he was available we
called him brad bradley helped us uh i
had a great call with jake uh the studio
it was written for two white brothers
and the studio called me
this guy peter and he goes you should
check into yaya uh he said
african-american guy and i said well i
don't know about that i don't know
because i felt it might be forced
whatever and then i
i said is yaya a real name i've never
seen his work and then i saw his work
and i'm like that guy's gonna be a movie
star and i want to work with him so then
i i i wrote in the kids and i figured
out okay this might be cooler to have it
this way because he gets adopted
they're trying to save the life of this
guy they both live in a rough
neighborhood but they're trying to save
this kid
and he gets adopted into a bank robbing
family uh and i loved working with the
actors and aza was always uh
my first choice right off the bat but uh
it was it was a you never know what you
get and just the vibe that we had
between the actors was was great
camaraderie something that no one in
this audience is going to realize and
because i didn't believe it when uh you
told me but this was made i believe in
39 days
38 days
now for people that don't realize maybe
you can explain how long was your shoot
on say the first transformers movie or
any of the transformers movies
um
like let's just say uh
armageddon was 120 days because you're
putting the spacesuits each each
spacesuit needed five people craziest
crap in the world um
let me explain that
first day ben affleck way down we
wrecked we're shooting in the badlands
and uh
dakotas and
i got a microphone or whatever to to to
the actors i said they're walking out of
plane crash and
wind machines 100 mile an hour winds and
all of a sudden i see
ben affleck
like
trying to hit his face mask
face shield
and they had real nasa like uh like
locks on their uh helmets and
i'm like god god what's going on ben ben
what's going on so we have to run
literally like a football field toward
and he was trying to find a rock to bust
his mask because he couldn't breathe
because the air things shut so that's
why it was complicated so that was a
long shoot
transformers are usually about 100 days
to about 90 something days um
this
this one was 38
a normal movie shoots about 20 to 30
shots a day
luckily i'm a fast shooter that's one of
the things i'm good at is just a shot
maker very fast and like very efficient
um leapfrogging my cameras
um
so we were shooting about 120 shots a
day and that's real
but it would help the movie and help the
performances because as an actor if
you're trying to keep that level of
tension
it's very exhausting to to to go to a
trailer come back and
to do that you want to you want to shoot
it fast so you keep that level of
tension up for their performance all
right
how many cameras do you typically use
for ambulance how many cameras were
typical
uh at all times
well we would have
uh komodos which is a smaller little red
we would have drones we would have like
10 cameras but not on every shot
sometimes sandbags sometimes just
putting them around uh
me operating my dp
an operator
some bagged cameras so yeah there's a
shot in the movie and i could be wrong
about this but there's a police and a
lot of police cars get destroyed in this
movie but there's one where it feels
like it
crashes into a camera um is that was
that camera destroyed
um i don't think so i know i i we
actually red said we want to have you
destroy a camera and put it on screen
and we kept trying to destroy them and
they wouldn't get destroyed
but no it was actually in a housing
there is um in all every movie you make
you do these crazy
fn shots but in this movie
there it goes to another level because
of the the way you use drones so can you
talk a little bit about how had you been
thinking about using drones before and
what was the inspiration for using
extensive drone shots in this film so i
always try to
uh come up with new stuff and and this
movie because there's a short shoot not
a lot of money
um
and i'll tell you a little story
spielberg
who i'm friends with i said i said in um
war of the worlds i said when tom cruise
middle of the movie toward the second
third act tom cruise runs to a hill and
you see these planes
going past the camera and he looks over
a hill and you don't see over the hill
like stephen stephen why
why didn't we get to see over the hill
that looked like cool [ __ ] that was
going to see and he goes ah five million
dollars so it's five million dollars in
a cut i cut it i cut it
and i'm like well that's the scene i
wanted to see
well i cut it you know and
what it made me think of
is
i've had all the money in the world he's
had all the money in the world and it's
great as a director to put
you know to tie your hand one hand
behind your back and have limitations
that's a challenge a movie needs to be a
challenge for a director
and
it's cool to just be i can't tell you
how much fun it was to
uh first of all my cops around the world
like my movies so i get away with a lot
of stuff okay
miami is where i live most of the time
miami cops uh
you know they'll let us get away with
[ __ ] i'm with walberg and dwayne johnson
and anthony mackie and it's me with the
camera and the sound guy and we got a
dead body and we're in a van and
mark's just like we have no police
escort he just starts driving we are
laughing mark is driving he mark's a
great driver walmart and he's driving
through the city
and cops would look at him and he goes
oh hey sweetheart how are you babe
immediately we keep driving we're
laughing the bot the dead bodies went
rolling around
and
that is fun that's just great stuff
that's where you feel like you're in
film school again and it just gets back
down to basics and that's kind of what
this movie was
cut to okay i i try to come up with cool
shots on on movies even though i have
less money less less toys but i'm like
okay drone work is sort of boring okay
and i'm like how can i like change this
up so i started looking at these 19 year
old kids these drone racers some of the
best in the world and
um i got them
we kind of tricked out some of their
cameras
um
and they would do [ __ ] that is just
amazing and i'm like i was tough on them
i always liked the sean connery to them
i'm saying yeah dude i want you to fly
through that that that [ __ ] explosion
you do and she's 19 years old you do
yeah
don't [ __ ] it up because you get
i i screw around with people but i do it
it's like a tough love thing and they
actually do it um i said yeah i want you
you saw one of the the he goes right
under the cars and jumping over the
thing i said yeah he goes did he get to
practice i said no dude i'm doing this
jump once we got them
and um
but seriously you always have a fire
marshal
for safety on sets and
a lot of drone people might not be as
good he saw these kids work and just the
skill level they had
and he would let him like
no one would ever let you fly two feet
from city hall with the with the
literally the radar towers and the cell
towers right there i mean these kids
were just
dive bombing and
um
you know you just challenge them and
then they said we've never ever had a
director allow us to do any of this so
it's just kind of creates a new kind of
language there also you have helicopters
in this movie that are very close to the
ground
and um i i
is that normally allowed or did is that
special permits
you don't need special permits for that
you need special permits to go under the
bridge i wrote that scene on a sunday i
said i need a where are you going where
are you going
we're going to wait just go and come
back
very rude
[Laughter]
so um
wait all the way first don't worry okay
i'm kidding i'm kidding okay
so i wrote that on a sunday and and i
worked with fred north who's one of the
great helicopter pilots french guy
um
and another pilot i work with they're
really amazing flyers uh
it's very dangerous work when you work
with these people that's why you need to
work with the best um
we got approval to go under the bridge
uh we shot that scene you saw there in
two and a half hours all right that's
fast and
um
you know i'll tell you yaya
uh i i told jake i said right jake um
there's a helo that's gonna come by and
it's gonna be about 20 feet from you
don't worry this is what they do this is
what they've been doing you know i i've
flown with them for 25 years
and um he goes okay okay
and he didn't see the helo because the
gila was way up there and a dive bombs
him and it comes comes down he comes
right by him i said and he shot shot at
and he gets in the thing they start
getting chased
and
uh like i put yaya
you know we would have a stunt driver in
there that's a stuntman hanging out the
side but that's jake actually at the
door shooting at a real helo um
uh but yaya
i just learned this today from yaya
this is what he said on milwaukee
because i'm in the porsche cayenne which
has a crane arm it's a very bmw this
time and it's a crane arm that goes it's
a very fast car and the arm kind of can
move around and it's it's controlled by
four people in there
and i'm in there with the the the
operators and i'm doing the zoom and
whatnot
and
uh yaya i've got a radio to yaya we're
right outside his window
and he gets on the radio he's driving
about 55 miles an hour yaya's a very
good driver by the way we train him
stunt people before the movie
and he gets on the radio he goes mike
this is the craziest [ __ ] in the world
you got two [ __ ] ambulances but
i mean two [ __ ] healers behind
me i said yaya get off the [ __ ]
walkie-talkie and focus
so those are real helos right off the
side of him and
what he told me today he goes because it
was the craziest [ __ ] i've ever done i
put a live stream to my buddy
in the ambulance and he put his phone on
all right that was pretty funny hear
that but um
it just gives more authenticity to the
movie but you know you i'm extremely
safe as a director and i don't take it
for granted at all i mean we did over a
thousand stunts not even a band-aid on
this movie was used so um
uh
you know i like uh i got i got crap i
did that instagram uh posting okay and
they censored the thing it's it's it's
the explosion where the ambulance comes
through the cars that's all real it's a
ratchet it's very very violent um i've
done more of those probably than anybody
in the world
uh i work with the best crew
um
if you look at the instagram thing my
assistant shot it and
i'm in the fire black fire suit and i'm
standing up on the dolly because i might
[ __ ] up my camera because i the
ambulance might hit me we've got two
catch cars that the cars are made to be
our blockers like i could dive back and
my my dolly grip has a car there by a
curb um
and we might screw up the dolly but that
stuff's replaceable
and what you're watching for because
it's microseconds if you've done that
you've done this a lot and you go
through the physics it's like as a
director not a lot of directors know how
to set up their own stunts and know you
always have to try to predict what could
go wrong
and
um
when these moments come up when these
scenes come up i am so serious on the
set and my crew gets very very serious
stunt people you hire the best of the
best each one has a different skill
level which which they're great runners
great drivers what you know you hire the
best of the best
and um
uh but i'm on the dolly and i'm standing
there i'm not even looking through the
camera because i want to be able to jump
back and i've got a monitor where i'm
watching but what i'm watching because i
can't the ambulance is being pulled
by a wire
uh it's going 50 something miles an hour
and it goes to a cable and a truck is
pulling it like that way it's coming
through as soon as it comes through
those hits those cars
um
electronic cable cutter cuts it so what
you watch for
we invented on armageddon a car flipper
so we know it's only going to go 15 feet
and the thing you're watching for is
that violent thing it's a car we wrap it
with the cable and it gets pulled and it
starts to spin violently but it's
getting pulled with such force it's
going that way it's not going to come
this way it's going to go that way
because of the force of the cable the
cable is super super strong
so
um
and i'm i'm i we go through over and
over with the stunt people where they
are because those are the ones i'm
concerned about
um uh
one stunt person hung in there a micro
second too long and so what i'm watching
for is when that ambulance comes through
and hits you want to make sure it's not
coming this way if it turns this way i'm
in trouble okay
so it's
assistant shot it from over here the
over-the-shoulder most dangerous looking
shots when you do action
um so it looks more dangerous but i see
that it's coming and i know that it's a
couple feet not past me but it's not
going to be it can't make a right turn
all right
so that i know that i am safe at that
time but i'm concerned about the
stuntman that's coming to me
and um he's going to get wedged because
he's running right to the dolly he was
supposed to go past my dolly but he was
running right to it
and the ambulance hit is at 10 miles an
hour i had plenty of time to jump off
the stump person i knew was fine and i
raised my arms
and
because i knew that was a perfectly
planned stunt i think the mayor gave me
[ __ ] the governor gave me [ __ ] uh
instagram like censored it but that was
a perfect plan stunt so
i wanted to let the audience ask like
yeah yeah come on so let's go
real fast guys because i know there's
some real big fans of yours in this
audience i know this person right there
is a huge fan
rapid fire it all has to be fast
i just want to say before any anything
i'm like your biggest fan of all time
you inspire me to want to become a
director transformers age of extinction
is my favorite movie of all time
transformers one is when i learned i
wanted to become a director
transformers age of extinction is my
favorite movie of all time transformers
one is when i knew i wanted to be a
movie director and i'm actually um
because of your influence i'm actually
going to art center college of design i
know yeah because of you yeah
yeah i actually just got off a movie
suit today to like come to this event so
yeah so um
one question i had i wrote it down
because it's kind of a uh
well it's kind of important um
yeah yeah you should go to your teacher
you say yeah i'm quitting school because
bait just gave me a job
[Laughter]
i'm actually going to ask you um how
would you recommend like aspiring
directors get into the industry in order
to um
he said rapid fire so i'm sorry yeah no
yeah i i apologize
um
how would you recommend uh aspiring
directors get into the industry in order
to like eventually make the kind of
movies that you make and also are you
hiring by the way
very funny okay um
listen there's no se it's not like a
doctor we go pre-med
boom become a doctor
um
you know you have to
you gotta knock down doors all right
it's not gonna come to you and it's like
you could shoot a movie on an iphone
still you know i mean i do funny videos
on iphones and the iphone's got some
great stuff to it
um
you just have to shoot and you have to
you got to figure out what you really
love do you love editing do you love
sound do you love
um
uh producing i mean it's just if you
want to be a director
you you
you have to learn how to deal with
people you have to learn time is money
you know you've got to get your dreams
on the screen but you've got to um
inspire your crew
and
it's a it's a it's literally
directing is exhausting and it's it's
literally
it's like a sporting event but you it
doesn't stop the train once it goes it
doesn't stop and
and you gotta you gotta bring it in on
budget you know so um
but i would recommend just shooting
short stories um
and uh that's what i would do
um we influenced by the movie um wild
bunch by sam pekin paul because he uses
lots of quick cuts it's very bloody very
violent like some of your films and made
me think you saw that movie and someone
outperformed him
i have a new idea i'm gonna go around
and he's going to stay on the stage
i think okay we could change this yeah
i actually did my thesis my senior
thesis or one of them on the decline of
the western hero and if you look at
westerns if you study westerns uh they
reflect history you see how
um the mexican what is it the mexican uh
war we had and then we've got uh nazis
coming in and then you see the hero
where you would only shoot him in the
front and wild bunches where you shoot
the you would shoot your enemy in the
back it's the cli it was more the
vietnam era of war um and it was a very
inspirational uh movie because it's it's
like the decline of the western hero
you know i was very bloody um
that's inspiring but i'm just you can
look at how history plays in westerns
it's very interesting so i watched you
film a commercial for six hours and then
was politely asked to leave
it was very enjoyable what commercial it
was burger king and it was in glendale
okay yeah
yeah you were trying to get a dog to do
something that wasn't exactly coming off
i thought it looked great right but um
who asked you to leave
some lady
i hate that i i
that's great that's great so um i
i love the way your stuff looks and
another guy who i just adore
the way he shoots is tony scott
so love tony i was friends with tony was
very nice to me and i was very sad when
he passed but uh yeah go on that's what
i'm hoping for could you tell us a story
about
spending time with tony scott
uh you know what i i i was in college
and i i saw top gun uh with some
fraternity brothers in connecticut and
i'm like oh my god
wow see a lost ark i see this and you
hear the music you see tom cruise on the
thing and like it looked so cool and i'm
like this is what i want to do
you know
being taken under jerry bruckheimer don
simpson's wing who did topcon and
whatnot
or tony a lot tony was uh
very inspirational the the scott
brothers were very inspirational because
they came from commercials and um
uh so that's where i came from but it's
good that to me it was always about
becoming a movie director and it was
just stepping stones so like a director
when he was talking about
i had videos to do you know i was doing
a video story videos we were doing like
every week every other week then went on
to commercials
just but just meeting him and just
learning from him uh was great you know
keep going
come on
i feel like it's like a
um
yeah so i just think you're the goat as
far as action filmmaking goes yeah i
think everybody in this room can agree
that um i was just wondering um out of
all your movies um what what what movie
do you look at from yourself and say
this is my masterpiece
well i don't look at movies like i don't
like try to pat myself on the back i
mean they're fun things that have
done you look at movies as different
wars each time and you have a love for
each thing on movies
um
i mean one of the fun ones that i did
that that just like
i see it and makes me chuckle was paying
a gain you know
and with something it was like we did it
for 22 million bucks we had so much fun
doing it and it's so wacky and it's just
i don't know it was i think it's dwayne
johnson's best performance okay he quit
the day the week before and i'm like i
wrote this long letter and i'm like you
are gonna be my secret weapon and um
uh anyway so there's love for each movie
because it's all different feelings you
know
so
thank you
hey mike love the movie um i always tell
people when michael bay shoots an actor
he makes him a movie star so i'm curious
was there an actor growing up that you
wish you could go back and direct in a
movie like somebody you looked up to
you're like man if i had that actor in
my movie i would have made him
even a bigger movie star than he already
was
you know it's interesting um
asa um
i think it was day three and remember
we're shooting at a fast clip and we
just you're just getting to know
actors as you go because and every actor
is different like psychology wise like
like uh ed harris
you know i'm i'm my second movie
and i'm down low and
we're shooting in alcatraz in the real
place where birdman of alcatraz was
housed and it's kind of creepy
and ed harris is doing a scene his first
night he had a lot of dialogue
and i'm down low here and there's the
guy with the
uh
the effects smoke and
ed staying his stuff and he's just like
are you doing smoke are you doing smoke
he's like yelling like what the hell's
going on he's out of his
mind and third take would you stop doing
smoke
whoa
okay
but it was his process
it was his process and you learn that
was his process i love working with ed
harris because now i know how he works
he gets really riled up and his fifth
take are the brilliant takes sean
connery was the third the second to
third take
everyone every actor is different
um on this
uh
uh we were doing a shot where she gives
a finger to jake uh well it's a great
moment because she puts her hands up
she's like this and i wanted to he i i
told the sound guys i wanted to hear
that her brothers and sisters are
looking for her and you hear all the
sirens around and she's got a choice she
could run
and then she hears that heart thing and
that's so cool she runs back
all right and and you know it's like
kind of a love letter to first
responders here and she was running to
give the finger okay yeah it's um
she's running she gave the finger and
then when you change lenses when you go
to a longer lens you have to slow down a
little because you've got this huge ass
movie screen and if she's moving too
fast and it's a tight shot she's going
to whack where are you going dude
all right you go go we'll hold
so we she can whack around meaning like
boom boom and and you know a strobe on
the screen
um and i'm like hey slow down slow down
and
she doesn't know me i don't know her she
goes you're picking on me you're picking
what you get what are you i'm like
well come over here let's talk and she's
like
we getting our first like fight
and she's intense she's she's intense
and she's fun to hang out with but she's
intense and i'm like
listen to me i mean i'm just telling you
this camera sees different than your eye
and i know what i'm doing i can make you
great and she goes but you're picking on
me
and i said to her after i let her speak
i said i'm gonna make you better than
you've ever been
okay
and i'm very proud of her performance
she was a trooper beyond troopers and
she did a great job and i think we've
made a real discovery uh movies with her
because she's a great hero in this movie
uh just a quick question ambulance too
come on come on we got to keep going on
okay fair enough you know by the time
i'm 35 i want to do another movie
hey i was just wondering uh i'm jack uh
what random action movie i'm mike oh hey
okay jack
what random action movies are you into
recently or anything you're obsessed
with recently
i mean i'm having a brain fart right now
seriously um random action movies that
i've seen
i don't can we talk about a tv show
yellowstone baby yellowstone
i i really like jealousy
if actually they asked you to direct any
of yellowstone would you do it
you know
like i said i would not want to do star
wars five because i i as like ridley
scott said the greatest the toughest
thing for a director to do is create to
create the world and i like creating the
world but that might be fun i mean i
just the horses and the stetson hats and
just a beautiful landscape
it's fun it's a fun show
yeah yeah yeah
you know what i was on a horse once
with my parents
i was in palm springs and i had to climb
the stairs to get on the horse this is a
true story and i'm a kid and i get on i
don't even put my hands on this in the
stirrups maybe one foot or more foot i i
didn't even grab the reins and the horse
bolts and he runs over a gully okay and
i'm grabbing the horn and the hair on
the horse and i'm down low like that
movie what was the movie uh
the one with the kid the beach the horse
oh black stella black stallion okay so
we're running over a gulley we run we
run we're charging over a golf course
i'm passing guys with golf carts and the
whole thing and i'm looking behind and
i'm almost falling off this horse and
he's tearing down and i see these three
uh cowboys yeah yeah behind i'm like oh
my god
so anyway
um childhood horror story okay
before you ask the question i just want
to point out before this when i was
meeting people outside and checking
people in i it's very rare for me to
hear so many people say
i can't wait to see bay talk i can't
wait to be a part of this and also
not being serious like it's not oh it's
not usually like that and
no one is left like they go to the
bathroom but they come back that also is
not the norm most people people they
have [ __ ] to do
right i'm sorry for interrupting you
it's okay it's okay um i have a question
what drives you to make the movies the
way that you do is it the adrenaline the
passion the art the audience okay i'll
tell you uh personally i love to shoot i
i l i i just it's so much fun for me to
be involved and it's it's a it's a
i love working with crews i love like
everyone's input it's a collaborative
experience um
and uh when i don't like something you
don't know it but uh but it's fun and
it's it's
it's an adrenaline rush it's uh
um
i love working with actors uh it's so
exhilarating when you start hearing
music to your your scenes
it's so interesting when actors add so
much more
um
it's fun i mean you don't know when you
cut a movie it could be [ __ ] you'd have
no idea
um
this has been a fun one
watching with
crowds um
because
what directors do like a 350 person
house when you test it you watch body
language
and
you count how many people like we have
already two or three go the bathroom
during my talk okay so that's bad that's
bad all right because i only had six on
my 350 house when watching the movie all
right that was two hours okay
um well they did watch the movie and
then okay
should have gone before should have gone
before
uh so i actually work at the company
falc so i just which is [ __ ] ambulance
and uh i did do a set visit one day
while you're
i remember seeing you yes so uh movie
turned out great we uh loved it and uh
so i just want to say that up front um
but my question is would you ever be
interested in doing a horror film yeah i
i mean i you know uh the shining
i mean when you see those two little
twin girls oh my god [ __ ]
i i mean i saw that at the village
theater when i was young and like i was
an empty theater 1200 uh seat i saw it
in like a matinee or whatever i mean
it's terrifying i i i do like horror
movies i mean i saw
i saw the exorcist i think when i was 12
and i slept between my parents that
night okay
okay quick question
on a previous collider screening jerry
bruckheimer said that in one day you did
72 setups is that still the record for
you and what movie was that on no i i i
am now up to 120. we've done 120 on this
movie we did 120 many days that's
a crazy shoot could be like 20 no 20 25
30.
um
yeah but what listen i've been doing
this a long time and the thing is
there's too much
everything's too precious certain things
definitely have to be precious
but
this is a movie where the speed was was
it helped the adrenaline the movie
and um
uh so it was helpful on this movie to do
it like that it's not fun it's it's
tough i mean you but it's it was it's a
cool study for me and just to make it
let me tell you the hardest day for on
this okay
we had that gigantic bank area we had
the streets all blocked down i was it
was the la times building the city hall
right there
the the la uh pd headquarters right
there
and it's a major deal to get that and
they said this is the only time the last
time you were ever going to get this
corner this area and we had the scene
where the little blue car pulls up okay
and i'm like this is a no joke
uh and this is where it separates the
the
men from the boys okay and i'm like i'm
like oh my god i go to my dp we are so
screwed right now we have 19 minutes of
light right now and my dog who is a big
mastiff who's who's
227 pounds i have to get his ass into
that [ __ ] car okay and i'm like nitro
get in there he's like what the [ __ ] do
you want me to get in i don't fit i go
in an escalade all right and so he got
in there his head sticks out and i'm
like we grab a camera and like um
garrett comes out and he's like it's his
first day with me i'm like welcome to
bay humber welcome to bayhem baby
because he goes weekend rehearsal i said
no
all right and they were basically all
real cops not actors
and except for cedric who's
the actor who pushes uh my sealed seal
guy remy um
and uh
we had to shoot all that in 19 minutes
um so because the sun was dropping and
so anyway
yeah
he's definitely not trained
uh so
my question is like in all of your films
you create this sense of found family
found brotherhood amongst all the actors
every time how do you facilitate that on
set how do i what facilitate the sense
of found brotherhood or found family in
like all of your movies
yeah you might be right i actually
haven't thought like that um
go through the movies i mean ar
armageddon
yep
13 hours you're right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean
you know i used to always think my movie
archetype that i liked the the best was
like the
the normal
person becoming a hero
doing extraordinary things when they
never thought they could
um
it's like nick cage in the rock
uh he comes to my house and he's been
working out a lot and the first time
meeting him he goes yeah i've been
working out a lot and um i uh
well nick you're an fbi chemical weapons
expert as well i want to have my shirt
sleeves ripped off i'm like dude you've
never used a gun i mean it's kind of
weird don't you think
so it's always the to me i like the old
wise man
taking someone who's normal and turning
them into a hero i don't know it's just
something that's been interesting to me
this was an interesting movie because
you're dealing with two people one one
robbing a bank
and
doing it for a noble reason to save his
wife and then one who is just charming
everybody um and you like these guys
and it's it's a weird interesting
dynamic and and
i you know what i've found from
audiences they're sympathizing with
these guys and if you look at my movies
they've always been this rah-rah
pro-america and i just did press tours
in in
europe and the four different countries
and they go they go you
bae you've done movies that are so raw
around america but now i've seen through
some of your movies from pain and gain
which shows the narcissism of like kind
of instagram and whatnot and this this
you can you can be get become the
american dream and do it in all evil
ways and then you got 13 hours where
america is not going to come save your
ass and um and they've got to go in and
you know
uh six people have to fight back and um
turns into the whole group um
and then you've got this one where
you've got a military person coming back
and he's sort of screwed over by our
government
and um it's sort of weirdly the decline
of the american dream you know so it's
uh
i don't know
just a quick question did you play one
of the cops
well uh outside of the the bank say that
did you play one of the cops outside of
the bank no no okay you want to know
where i am i will tell you exactly where
i am okay when when jake holds those
baby booties remember low budget movie
when he holds the baby booties those are
my baby booties okay
okay and now i'm gonna give you the one
nugget this is the one nugget when he's
when when yaya holds that picture up and
he's looking he goes ah
mrs burns was my third grade teacher by
the way i just want you to know that
okay um
he holds a picture if you look at the
movie again you can actually see my mom
holding me as a baby okay and i never
greeked it out
true story
uh
michael thank you for your time for
being here one of my questions is what
you just said about you know a lot of
your movies are about america and
everything and i was just wondering
how do you get like the government to
like let you play with all the toys that
they have and i mean that's the coolest
thing like every time i watch your
movies i'm like how did he get him to do
that like let him get like play with the
helicopters and the carriers and
everything can you expand on that can i
follow up to that because in this in
this movie i believe the truck that is
the command center of the lapd was
something that's like a prototype i
could be wrong but i think it is a
prototype which goes to your point of
how the f do you keep on getting this
prototype equipment well
okay um uh the the
i i forgot what we've talked about today
because i've been talking for nine hours
um
uh
you i had there are 52 real cops in this
movie so basically everyone is real real
swat real snipers real undercover sis uh
uh
most of those people in the shootout
they're all real police
um
you know not great actors but they work
they feel real no seriously no seriously
but but the tactics a lot of the tactics
are all from them um i thought chases or
you just put a spike strip down whatever
but that's not how they do it they
really manipulate with hostage takers
they put pressure on off so that these
are all real stuff i mean literally it's
so much fun when you have 52 real police
on there you could go like that [ __ ]
yourself no i'm kidding i'm kidding and
that's a total joke this is a toad truck
no seriously um
the
having you know let you do get some
special things where like uh hey can we
get a helo uh lapd hilo flyby and two
minutes later hilo comes by i mean
that's fun um but no it's because
i i treat the military well um i'm
it's
i've become friends with so many people
in the military i've worked with the
pentagon a lot
and they know that i i treat them well
with respect
and i show how it really is
um
and they are an amazing group of people
that will put their lives on the line
even police paramedics all of them and
it's a it's a it's it's fascinating that
they give of themselves so much and they
don't get enough appreciation
um and you know it's true all right
um
but you know like like
his character will's character he comes
back and he can't get that surgery i
mean listen america kind of screws over
some of our soldiers coming back and
it's sad um
we take them for granted sometimes and
you know sometimes the governments are
planning wars that we don't need to be
in you know so
um i mean what's going on right now in
ukraine is uh is it's just in our
lifetime is is just it's it's
devastating
how did you get that prototype of that
uh command center
well we made it and they gave me a truck
and um
uh
but
you know i've been like uh uh the first
to use a bunch of the military weapon
systems uh
you know i mean when i asked when i was
in my third movie okay i go i go to nasa
i want the space shuttle and they go
okay and i'm like wow
wow i'm the only director in the world
to get it twice
you know and then i'm like
well i want the b2 uh a stealth bomber
for armor kid well no no no you can't do
that that's it needs to be moved into
the cover tonight we're shooting on a
military base edwards air force base
which is totally secure well we need to
move in the cover of night and i said
well can i get it well well okay okay we
can get it um and so they had on that
day on the shoot they had this line of
death and they had two military people
uh with machine with the m16s at that
time and bruce and the actors are there
and and
uh it they have a sign that says you
cross this line your lethal force will
be used
by lunchtime i was sitting in that
[ __ ] okay
okay all right
you just got to be good with gift of gab
here okay
[Laughter]
hey michael is there i've seen the rock
a hundred times i love that movie if i'm
really busy i'll catch it on tv i'll
still have to sit and watch uh is there
any truth there was a time where you
said you might have done a sequel
and is there any
is that something that would possibly
happen in the future or is that not
something you're interested in
i mean i i mean listen it was a it was a
great learning experience uh for me um
it was great working with those actors
um
but uh i mean they were asking me today
could have been could could it because
sean's characters have been uh james
bond and i'm like yeah that was always
thought of slightly in the movie um but
uh
i don't know not a sequel i don't know
do you have any plans on making another
transformer movie
i mean listen it was a great ride doing
it it really was fun um
uh but i it i'm i want to do other
things and uh
i love making movies
um
so i i like going from big to small you
know this is a small one
um
and uh hopefully i'll do a big one next
i mean if i'm not kicked out of the
business i don't know
i'm actually i uh i'm just gonna say
that i enjoyed your work on the
transformers movies but i'm very happy
that you're doing other things because
i want to see these other things
i just want to know what your favorite
uh scene to shoot in this movie was
um
you know it was a difficult team
but i liked it it was uh
when jake and yaya
uh go to poppies and they deliver the
money
um
you know every
there's every there's a scene in every
movie where it's very difficult
an actor won't throw a tizzy but like
there were a lot of words there was too
many words written in the scene and and
and um
you know we're shooting this is such a
fast clip
and we don't have it's not like mission
impossible where tom cruise can go back
three times and reshoot the scene over
and over and over i mean literally if we
didn't shoot it's on in the movie and
jake's like it has to be emotional it
has to be emotional it has to be
emotional
and this was jake's hot day every actor
has a right there's a day where it's
like this is really passionate for an
actor and
um because actors are out there and you
got under as a director you got to
understand that and and it has to be
emotional i'm like jake i mean i want to
cry right now i want it to be emotional
but we have three [ __ ] hours to
shoot this okay
so
um all kidding aside we shot but it
wasn't working
and um uh
we shot some stuff and then we came we
were lucky to come back because the
problem was this town was so busy we
couldn't get that location and we were
able to find it for get it for another
four hours and we came in and we shot it
and that was a tough scene but i i
really liked the scene because yaya
improv jake improved um i don't know i
really like that scene
do you
have any
plans in the imminent future to reunite
with jerry bruckheimer and also
is there a movie that you may have seen
over the classic movie and only a recent
movie where you had been like you're
watching it and as you're watching it
you're just left with the impression
that like damn they should have gotten
me or like i really or i could have made
that better okay there's a couple of
movies there's a couple movies where
uh i was sit i was given saving private
ryan before stephen okay steven
when i saw it that's the greatest movie
the greatest first scene of any movie
i've ever seen okay um i would have
never done a better job steven was
perfect for that um i was given um uh
blackhawk down and i'm like this is way
too violent there's no way anyone's
gonna go to this movie i am so glad
really ridley scott did that movie okay
um so i'm glad they didn't pick me thank
god okay and i didn't say yes um
uh
i think my first movie i was ever given
when i went to meet stephen when i was a
kid
the the desk of raiders lost ark story
he gave me small soldiers
and i didn't i said no to that um
it's kind of weird your first movie
you're offered and uh
uh i said no you the first movie i was
going for with a vengeance was speed
okay
i lost that movie okay
uh john devon did a great job i want to
follow up with what this gentleman said
is there any talk about you and jerry
bruckheimer doing anything
jerry and i are great friends um jerry
is an amazing producer let me give you
an idea about what a great producer is
so jerry's got the longest desk in
hollywood okay it was don simpson set
over here it's literally almost
it's almost like from that end of this
chair to about next to her that's how
long it is okay it's it's really true
and um
uh
when i'm doing when i was doing
armageddon jerry would come in like a
real producer like 11 30 in the morning
and i'm there at nine o'clock in the
edit room
and
um
he's like jerry was like the chinese
water torture guy it was like literally
drip trip he would make you feel bad but
like in a nice way it's like you come
into that room okay guys [ __ ] up today
like it makes you feel great okay
um
but uh
so i'm literally like in his office
waiting for him i said to jerry around
he goes well he's working out with the
trainer okay let me call them cause i
just
i said jerry hey i just read uh godzilla
was competing with us with armageddon
and i said jerry godzilla they have a
whole album
we don't have [ __ ]
and there was a long pause like this let
me call you back
three days later we had aerosmith
sitting in his edit room
that's a great producer um
uh
but we but jerry and i talk about uh
working together um
and uh i really can't wait to uh work
with him again
my last question of the night i'm
excited to see stop code by the way i've
heard really good things about top gun
uh
that
remember we talked about top gun just
for me
they know what i was i was hinting at
that that's something earlier
you know what i'm talking about um
maybe a screening um
anyway so uh my last question for you uh
what are you i bet you the director
won't be as fun as me no joseph is not
gonna be
no no chance um
what are you is i heard rumors about
robe apocalypse but what exactly are you
thinking about for the future
i mean ro i really do like robo
apocalypse there's a problem with this
that movie uh
uh
steven prepped it and um he asked me
after he saw 13 hours he'd like me to do
it but the problem is there's 30 million
because he was literally built stages
whatever so there's 30 million dollars
against the movie which would go on top
of the movie
um
so it would be very expensive because
you know you've gotta
you know
yeah recoup it yeah
so so do you know what you're going to
do next i mean i've got this movie that
uh an idea i created uh
14 years ago called black five that i'm
working on um which is a cool mission
movie it's a cool concept high concept
um there's a couple great world war ii
things um and then i don't know we'll
see
that's the thing and then i'm re
reconstituting platinum dunes with brad
fuller okay there we go
yeah okay i
am so curious about you in world war ii
doing a movie i'm i am literally floored
by this right now because i didn't know
you were even thinking about it yeah so
is is it like a story is it
one's a very very emotional story uh
that's pertinent for today and it's not
like an old man world war ii it's
dealing with young people during world
war ii
um
so uh i can't talk about it right now
but you know uh ladies and gentlemen
mr michael bay thank you guys thank you
guys thank you a lot of fun it was a lot
of fun hanging
you